thank you very much everyone for a very
big day today I want to start by saying
that love and prayers of every American
continue to be with our fellow citizens
who have lost a cherished friend or a
family member to the virus amidst our
grief we're making tremendous strides
against this invisible enemy thanks to
our aggressive campaign against the
virus and the extraordinary talent of
our medical professionals or mortality
rate remains roughly half of that of
many other countries and one of the
lowest of any country in the world and
that's due to a lot of a lot of things
but our medical professionals have been
incredible well since we announced our
guidelines on opening up America as we
call it see opening up America and we
had the word a gun I think we can add
the word probably again but that's what
it is we're opening up America again 20
states representing 40 percent of the US
population have announced that they are
making plans and preparations to safely
restart their economies in the very near
future so that's 20 states it's about 40
percent of our country they're moving
along pretty quickly three announced
today as you know and they're going to
be doing it safely they're going to be
doing it with tremendous passion there's
they want to get back to work the
country wants to get back to work
there's your time ago the Senate passed
the paycheck protection program and
health care Enhancement Act with
additional funding for the Paycheck
protection program hospitals and testing
a lot of money for all of them
especially for our workers and our small
businesses my administration has worked
aggressively with Congress to negotiate
this critical 482 billion dollar funding
package we reached a deal that includes
382 billion dollars and crucial small
business support to keep workers on the
payroll seventy-five billion dollars to
aid hospitals which really need the aid
and very badly very proud of that
and 25 billion dollars to support
coronavirus testing efforts I urge the
house to pass the bill and they're going
to be voting on it I imagine very very
soon I think while we're here and so
he's a very busy man as you know
secretary minuchin he's going to be
running back so I thought would do we'll
talk about that now and we'll take a
couple of questions on that and then he
can go and start phase four as the ink
is drying probably they'll be voting
tomorrow in the house but shortly
shortly and I think we have tremendous
support so Steve please come up say a
few words yeah Thank You mr. president
and thank you for all your work with us
to get this passed I'd especially like
to thank Mitch McConnell and Chuck
Schumer and the entire Senate for
passing this I'd also like to thank
Kevin McCarthy and Nancy Pelosi who have
been working with us round the clock as
well and our chief of staff mark meadows
who was also very instrumental in this
let me just comment we've had tremendous
support for the PPP this gives us
another 310 billion dollars for the PPP
we look forward to the house passing
this tomorrow in being up and running
quickly after that this also gives us 50
billion dollars for disaster loans idle
loans that will allow the SBA to make
300 billion dollars of disaster loans
all for small businesses also allows us
as the president said more money to
hospitals and unprecedented amount of
money for testing and and again I think
we understand hospitals not only the
hospitals that have been impacted by
coronavirus but more importantly many
hospitals that have been shut down and
making sure that the doctors and nurses
get money now let me make just one more
comment on the program we have over a
million companies that have received
this with less than 10 where
so there is very broad participation and
in really small business I will comment
there have been some big businesses that
have taken these loans I was pleased to
see that Shake Shack returned to the
money we will be putting out some fa Q's
there is a certification that people are
making and I asked people just make sure
the intent of this was for business that
needed the money we'll put out an FAQ
but again the intent of this money was
not for big public companies that have
access to capital so mr. secretary are
you gonna request that those other
companies obviously Shake Shack was not
alone in being a big company that
they've got money in this replay you're
gonna ask them to return that money yep
Harvard is gonna pay back the money and
they shouldn't be taking it so Harvard's
going to you have a number of I'm not
gonna mention any other names but when I
saw Harvard they have made one of the
largest endowments anywhere in the
country maybe in the world I guess and
they're gonna pay back that money I just
want to clarify because certain people
on the PPP may have not been clear and
understanding the certification so we
will give people the benefit of the
doubt we're gonna put in FAQ out explain
the certification if you pay back the
loan right away you won't have liability
to the SBA and to Treasury but there are
severe consequences for people who don't
test properly this certification and
again we want to make sure this money is
available to small businesses that need
it people who have invested their entire
life savings
we appreciate what's going on and in
their hiring people back how are you
going to ensure that those small
businesses those small restaurants cafes
bars who did not get the money last time
around are going to get it this time
well as I said you know there are a
million a million of these companies
that did get it that are very small
working with the banks were extremely
pleased that the small banks did great
20% of the loans were made by banks of a
billion unless 60% by by 20 billion in
less and the the big banks also we want
everybody to participate there's no a
lot of money back in the program
and we look forward to all these small
businesses getting access to fund brett
it's great to see you thank you for
secretary and you know
estimate how long this is going to take
that other pot of money obviously went
quickly
she was assume this is wondering of
quickly as well well let me just say I
mean you know kind of we're pleased with
the success of this program and how
quickly this got up operationally we've
we've put out more money in these SBA
loans than in the last 10 years of SBA
so I want to thank all the banks that
have worked really hard we knew that
when we passed this originally if there
was full take out we wouldn't have
enough money that's why we've worked
with Congress for more money and this is
gonna you know we've already impacted
about 30 million workers they'll be
they'll be a lot more so we look forward
to this having a big impact on the
economy yesterday the president said
look into the issue of felons the
criminal addictions I gain access to
some of these programs we worked with
the White House on this there were
actually much more onerous restrictions
in the SBA program there were people who
had misdemeanors that that weren't
allowed to access the program it was
much longer than five years and you know
we very much because of the criminal
reform legislation that was passed and
the work that's been done in the White
House by Jared and others we
specifically designed the program in the
five years was significantly shorter
than what had been done before so we had
already taken that into account right
now we're not going to do that but I
want to just emphasize we did take this
into account there were a lot of people
that wouldn't have access previously and
we changed those regulations the
president talked about a phase four I
know we all understand the circumstances
and why businesses need this but how
many more phases can we afford to have
or can businesses expect to have a do
see up phase five a phase six of phase
seven what's your thinking on this well
first of all I very much appreciate the
president's support for phase four he
put out a tweet as the president said we
would look forward to phase 4 would be
infrastructure the president's been
talking about infrastructure since the
campaign roads bridges broadband
especially broadband now to rural
America is very important
we've talked about incentives for
restaurants sports entertainment because
these businesses have been impacted the
president has talked multiple times
about a payroll tax cut and we've also
we're talking about in the case of
states the states we've heard from the
governors and the fiscal issues of the
state's I think phase four will most
likely be what we need I think based
upon what we're seeing and the reopening
of the economy and the amount of money
we're putting in and working with the
Federal Reserve on 13-3 I think you're
gonna see a lot of liquidity and we look
forward to business rebounding
especially later this summer just real
quick to follow up and the PPP program
is this the last tranche of money you
think you're gonna need for small
businesses we would expect this is the
last tranche but obviously we can always
reconsider that but this is a lot of
money going out again let me just be
clear you know it's it's another 310
billion here and another 300 billion of
loans that's over six hundred billion
dollars putting into small businesses
which are the backbone of the economy
50% of the private payroll for us to
comment what the cost is we'll work with
Congress on that and we'll consider it
fellows gonna do a different way of
thinking about the need for oversight
independent oversight on behalf of the
taxpayer we haven't do any oversight we
supported in the last legislation let me
be very clear we have a new Inspector
General the president has already picked
someone for that position we look
forward to the person being confirmed we
have an oversight committee of Congress
that many of them have already been
appointed and let me just say we put up
last week for full transparency we have
no obligation to do this we put up you
can go to Treasury gov full transparency
on the money that had been sent out on
the PPP across states showing all the
big lenders how it was distributed no
one lender did more than 4% showed the
businesses so again the president I very
much believe in full transparency we're
spending a lot of money and we want to
make sure that it's done effectively and
fairly thank you you started by thanking
the leaders in the House and the Senate
can you tell us more about how easy or
hard it was to deal with both sides well
we've been working around the clock
I think there's been very good
bipartisan support to get this done the
the Congress is coming together
understanding the importance of this and
we've been working round the clock for
days so this is important legislation it
was a lot we spoke to a lot of people
mark meadows has been fantastic as I
said it's great to have him here in the
White House I couldn't have done this
without him working on this with me and
the president and vice president have
been available to us around the clock so
this was a big team effort collaboration
of the Democrats absolutely we couldn't
have done this today without unanimous
consent and the Democrats being on board
and we look forward to this being passed
on a bipartisan basis tomorrow this is a
real example of the country coming
together to fight this virus again I
think we're not we're not at the point
of designing that like every other bill
we will work with senators on on both
sides on a bipartisan basis I can tell
you there's a lot of support
particularly for things like broadband
and especially what's going on today but
the president has talked about you know
I was on the campaign with the president
we've been talking about bridges and
tunnels and rebuilding this country for
years so the president wants to make a
big investment in this this Mitch
McConnell we see the 17 billion dollars
portion of cares reserved for companies
credit being critical for national
security and also will all companies fit
into that at all per the president's
truth
so we're in the process of putting out
guidance that that part was really
designed for national security companies
that are either major suppliers to the
Department of Defense were companies
that have top-secret clearance so the
this that national security provision
was was very clear when we did that the
president has asked me to work with the
Secretary of Energy
obviously the energy business is very
important to us this has national
security issues but different and we
look forward to both looking at what
existing capabilities we have and that
will be something we may need to go back
to Congress and get additional funding
similar to the airplanes with your line
bailout a completely different situation
I mean what you have with the airlines
is you know we had a very very good
airline industry because of the virus
they basically shut down we have a
situation now with the the oil business
partially because of the virus okay for
Less demand but partially also because
of too much supply but you know the
president is determined we want to
maintain our energy independence and the
president has asked me to look at all of
our options and what we're doing that
obviously it's a pretty extraordinary
situation where you saw the front month
of oil futures trade negative on the
issue of the fourth stimulus bill and
aid to state and local governments
any thoughts on whether that money
should be proportionate to have the rate
of infection in state so that'd be
interesting but way too early to
consider that whatever we do will do on
a bipartisan basis the president has
listened to the governor's I've had the
opportunity on multiple video conference
calls with the President and the Vice
President we're reaching out to a lot of
people there's a lot of states that have
been impacted but way too early to
figure out that level of design if a
large company applies for one of these
loans and they manipulates or works the
system or work some loopholes to get it
what are some consequences to you know
if a large company tries to get on these
PPP loans what can you do well you use
the word manipulate I'm going to give
people the benefit of the doubt again
we're going to put up very clear
guidance so that people understand what
the certification is what it means if
you're a big company again there is a
provision for you know where there are
multiple affiliates that people can
access this but the intent was not for
companies that have access to plenty of
liquidity and other sources and and
again if to the extent these companies
didn't understand this and they repay
the loans that will be
okay and if not they'll be potentially
other consequences can you talk about
what those consequences again you can
look at the certifications there they're
quite significant how many jobs have
been saved with all the money that's
going out well I can't tell you the PPP
so far is over 30 million jobs and and
again that doesn't account for other
money that we've sent out and again
we're very pleased the direct deposits
have gone out we've started sending out
the cheques we're also going to be
supplementing our capability and sending
prepaid debit cards so we can get money
out quickly to people so everything that
the president has had us working on is
providing significant stability in the
economy while we're dealing with this
difficult time when for medical reasons
we closed down major parts of the
economy thank you very much good
question so the noble fight against the
invisible enemy is inflicted a steep
toll on the American workforce as we all
know millions of Americans sacrificed
their jobs in order to battle the virus
and save the lives of our fellow
citizens we have a solemn duty to ensure
these unemployed Americans regain their
jobs and their livelihoods therefore in
order to protect American workers I will
be issuing a temporary suspension of
immigration into the United States you
heard about that last night by pausing
immigration will help put unemployed
Americans first in line for jobs as
America reopens so important it would be
wrong and unjust for Americans laid off
by the virus to be replaced with new
immigrant labor flown in from abroad we
must first take care of the American
worker take care of the American worker
this pause will be in effect for 60 days
after which the need for any extension
or modification will be evaluated by
myself and a group of people based on
economic conditions at the time
disorder will only apply to individuals
seeking a permanent residency in other
words those receiving green cards
big factor will not apply to those
entering on a temporary basis as we move
forward we'll examine what additional
immigration related measures should be
put in place to protect us workers we
want to protect our US workers and I
think as we move forward we will become
more and more protective of them this
Pozzo a new immigration will also help
to conserve vital medical resources for
American citizens a short break from new
immigration depending on the time we're
talking about will protect the solvency
of our health care system and provide
relief to jobless Americans today
vice-president Penn's visited the
hard-working men and women of General
Electric health care in Madison
Wisconsin who are working three shifts a
day to quadruple their production of
ventilators were way ahead of schedule
on ventilators as you know that's why
it's never brought up by the media they
don't like to bring things up when we're
doing so well ge is also working with
Ford to make 50,000 ventilators in the
next 100 days more than our entire
country
typically produces in a very long period
of time doing that in a matter of a few
weeks and a few days earlier today I had
a very productive meeting with Governor
Cuomo as you probably saw to discuss his
statewide testing strategy and how we
can work together to help expand it with
the goal of doubling testing in the next
few weeks and New York State will be
continuing to control the testing of
their citizens and will also manage
their state and local laboratories they
have a lot of great laboratories there
more than anybody would ever have known
frankly the federal government will work
along with the state on the national
manufacturers and distributors together
will all work together to help them
secure additional tests and we hope that
this model will work with the other
states as
well I think it will for the most part
New York has a lot of very exceptional
laboratories but most of the states
dudes you saw the chart yesterday most
of the states do
I'm proud of the relationship my
administration is forged with New York
and I can say very honestly with New
York State in New York City they've been
terrific to work with the New York
metropolitan area has been the epicenter
of the outbreak here in America and the
federal government has spared no expense
or resource to get New Yorkers the care
they need and the care they deserve
we've sent over 5 million masks we had
five million masks and now that number
as of about two days from now will be
more than doubled
thousands of ventilators in fact so many
ventilators that the governor is going
to be sending up some to to
Massachusetts and a couple of other
locations we have a great deal of
ventilators which people thought would
be impossible about a month ago
thousands of hospital beds and the USNS
comfort was sent as you know to New York
and it was originally for more of a
normal medical purpose and we changed it
over so that it could take care of
people that had the unfortunate
circumstance of going through the
problem that we that we know so well
unfortunately that we know so well I
said from the beginning that no American
who needs a ventilator would be denied a
ventilator and we have kept that promise
all over the United States think of that
other countries are desperate for
ventilators they have many deaths
because they don't have a ventilator and
I've asked Andrew if we could bring the
comfort back to its base in Virginia so
that we can have it for other locations
and he said we would be able to do that
Javits Center has been a great help to
them but we'll be bringing the ship back
at the earliest time and we'll get it
ready for its next mission which will
I'm sure would be a very important one
also
but it was it was an honor they they
reconverted it after I got there into
handling an event that they were not
expecting to be handling the FDA has now
authorized more than 50 diagnostic tests
including as of late last night the
first test that a patient can take home
you can take it at home and it's a
highly accurate
LabCorp intends to make the home
collection kits available to consumers
in most states with a doctor's order in
the coming weeks we also a for different
antibody tests already authorized tests
will help identify individuals who can
donate convalescent plasma thus
providing potentially life-saving
antibodies to American patients dr. Hahn
we'll be providing you with an update on
these developments and a few moments
he's done a great job at the FDA we
continue to gain ground in the war
against the unseen enemy and I see light
at the end of the tunnel I actually see
a lot of light at the end of the tunnel
and we're starting the process we're
starting a very very powerful important
process you see that people are getting
very anxious they want to get going they
want to get back to their jobs they want
to make money they want to take care of
their families so the light is getting
brighter and brighter every day and with
that if I could I'll ask dr. Burks to
come up and then dr. Hahn thank you very
much
[Music]
Thank You mr. president so I'm looking
at all of the information across the
United States we do see improvement
across all the large metros I know you
know that we've been talking about the
New York metro area New York City Rhode
Island Connecticut Long Island and
really we do start to see improvement
there and we see improvement even now in
in Rhode Island and Connecticut the
Detroit Metro is doing quite well with
significant declines now New Orleans is
nearly backed to their baseline of where
they started for new infections we also
are seeing improvements in Chicago and
Boston and that has been a great concern
for us over the last several weeks if
they appear now to be flattening both
also Philadelphia and Houston Atlanta
Nashville Baltimore Indianapolis and st.
Louis also appear to be flattening the
DC metro area we don't see a decline yet
so I'm hopefully all of you is still
social distancing and doing everything
that you can I wanted to remind
everybody of two points when we brought
up and the president put out the
guidelines for opening up America again
it was very clear to use data and to
really work together to mitigate against
any resurgence and also critically to
protect the vulnerable and what we're
seeing across rural America and some of
the smaller pop population states is
we're still seeing outbreaks in
long-term care facilities and we asked
everyone in phase 1 to make sure that
they continued their social distancing
and public to ensure that the vulnerable
with comorbidities and other conditions
and among the elderly where we're
staying at home and making sure we're
still providing service to them but as
individual Americans as we begin to open
up we also made it very clear that
individual Americans need to continue
all of their hygiene pieces ensuring
social distancing washing hands not
touching their face and making sure
they're not bringing the virus home to
vulnerable individuals within
household and remember those were to
continue through all three phases and so
really want to call people's attention
again to the guidelines we are
continuing to see outbreaks in nursing
homes and in confined spaces and I think
as Americans we want to stop that and we
have the ability to do that by really
paying attention to the guidelines that
were to be in all three phases and so
I'm calling on the states again to note
that an informed community and
knowledgeable community as a protected
community so make sure all of your
states have your cases visible to the
communities so they can make decisions
and understand where the virus is in
their community and understand how to
tackle it with their state and local
governments this will be absolutely
critical and there's surveillance that
we called for to find asymptomatic
before people get sick with as an early
warning signal we ask for those to be in
the federal clinics in our inner city
more vulnerable areas among indigenous
populations and of course in our
long-term care facilities and prisons we
really want to support state and local
governments to move forward on these
critical monitoring to protect
individuals that may be in the most
critically vulnerable States we will
continue to see mortality and deaths
among our American citizens particularly
in the cities as they begin to move past
peak because deaths will lag and so we
really need to continue to unite and
really really really support our health
care providers who are still on the
front lines they have been on the front
lines now for weeks and weeks and weeks
and so no matter what city they have
been in they have not seen the relief
that we've been able to talk about it
the at light at the end of the tunnel
because of the delay in hospitalizations
and deaths so to our health care
providers to our respiratory therapists
and to everyone in the labs thank you
for the work that you're doing to
protect Americans and give us one of the
lowest mortality rates in the entire
world thank you
Thank You mr. president
and I just want to echo what dr. Burke
said just a few short months ago I was
one of those doctors on the front lines
and I know how terrific they're working
and how well they're doing for the
American people and I shout out to them
for just the wonderful work that they
that they do every day so President
Trump asked the FDA to remove all
unnecessary barriers that were in place
to help with the development of both
diagnostics and therapeutics and we have
done that I'm here to give you an update
on FDA's efforts around serologic tests
which as you know are antibody tests
which detect in the blood the natural
immunity that someone might develop in
response to infection in this case Kovan
19
these aren't diagnostic tests but these
are tests that actually detect the
antibody so an indication that one has
had the infection and has responded and
I think it's important for everyone to
understand that the timing of the
response of the antibody to the
infection isn't completely known but we
know that it takes some time to actually
develop that and there's two types of
antibody responses that can be detected
and the antibody tests are just one
piece of the larger response that you've
heard in the America returning to work a
plan that the president has with Task
Force has developed and this pandemic is
truly unprecedented in nature and you'll
see reports around the world of
different antibody tests that have been
used and I think that's a reflection of
the fact that we're just learning to and
beginning to understand what that
response looks like and many of these
tests have different characteristics
that allow to detect at different points
in the infection I do want to address
one issue that we are laser focused on
at FDA and that is in an effort to
provide laboratories and health care
providers the early access to tests we
issued a policy earlier in March that
allowed test developers the opportunity
to quickly get their tests to market and
address the needs of the nation as posed
by the epidemic in March we provided
this regulatory flexibility to
manufacturers and here's what we
required of them the manufacturers had
to validate their tests we call it self
validation similar to what many test
developers in the world
have done they had to notify FDA that
they had performed that validation and
then they had to label their products
appropriately in the package insert with
information about the validation as well
as the fact that it's not a diagnostic
test that it's an antibody test and the
bottom line here is that FDA still
expects manufacturers and test
developers to validate their antibody
tests even under this revised policy now
we've done a couple of things to
actually help end users to help
laboratories providers etc States in
terms of their use of these antibody
tests one is that we're working with CDC
and NCI to actually validate some of the
more than 90 manufacturers who have
notified us that they brought their
tests to market to do an independent
validation and that process is going to
expect to hear more information this
week about that and we will provide that
information in a transparent manner and
we also want to go after anyone who is
office saying that that test has been
authorized or has or has been approved
by the FDA but actually hasn't and we've
authorized for applications for antibody
tests and a hundred and forty tests
developers are pursuing applications for
us as we speak so it's not okay for
someone to say that a testaments
authorized or approved by FDA when it
hasn't and we are pursuing them both by
direct contact with the manufacturers
but also at the border and so we have
increased these interdiction efforts and
we will continue to outreach and do and
do that with the manufacturers to make
sure that we provide the most up-to-date
information to the n use of these
products and we will continue to do make
all of our efforts both in the
Diagnostics and the therapeutics to help
America open up again Thank You mr.
president
[Music]
you're speaking of 140 different
developers more than 90 manufacturers
how many of these tests actually work so
as I mentioned the 90 that have come
forward and said they're marketing the
u.s. they are required by us to have
self validation and they're required to
label that appropriately in their
package insert and they also said that
we're what we're doing is we're working
with folks around the country but here
at home in the US government with the
NCI and CDC to validate some of those
tests that have come forward to us so
we're actually doing some independent
about it validation so far so we don't
have those results yet I expect to have
more results this week but we will be
transparent about those results because
you think it's very important and your
question is superb in that if someone
wants to use a test that's come to
market really it's important to read the
information that's in the package insert
but often in some of those cases it's
also important for the independent labs
to do the validation also and you may
have seen reports in the press of labs
around the country that have done that
we've actually reached out to the many
academics and we will be including that
information in the information that we
generate as well to provide to the
American people there was a study out of
the VA today on hydroxychloroquine that
found a higher mortality rate compared
to those who that standard of care I
know this isn't a large-scale clinical
trial but since this drug is out there
and people are using it can you give
some takeaways from that study did that
change your thinking at all so this
study is a small retrospective study at
the VA and and similar to the data we
talked about before with the French
study this is something that a doctor
would need to consider as part of a
decision in writing prescription for
hydroxychloroquine and as I've mentioned
from this podium in and other venues
before with what FDA is going to require
is data from clinical trials randomized
clinical trials hydroxychloroquine
placebo to actually make a definitive
decision around safety and efficacy but
the preliminary data are helpful to
providers and doctors I want to ask them
to incorporate the data as we have it
come forward and it's not definitive
data it doesn't help us make a decision
from a regulatory point of view but
doctors should incorporate that in the
decision making them
on a one-on-one basis just the timeline
on the clinical trials and when we will
be getting a readout of that data so the
good news is we have over 30 clinical
trials now the settings are very
different they're in the outpatient
setting they're in the inpatient setting
and also I think very importantly in
what we call the post exposure
prophylaxis meaning if you're a
healthcare work or a frontline provider
and you've been exposed to the virus
take the drug for a period of time to
see if you can prevent the development
of illness related to the virus so all
those trials are in progress and will
probably be early summer before we get a
readout in addition to the test that we
already have and we have tested more
people than anybody anywhere in the
world by far by very far well I think
wonderful I had drunk when I wondering
if you're concerned this this VA study
showed that actually more people died
they use the drug that they didn't and
I'm wondering if the Governor Cuomo
brought you back any results no I'm
discuss it and I don't know of the
report obviously there have been some
very good reports and perhaps this one's
not a good report but we'll be looking
at it we'll have a comment on a panel of
experts at the NIH is actually now
recommending against the use of
hydroxychloroquine in combination with
z-pak which is something you okay I'm
always willing to take a look Brett
other subject you were signing the
executive order when do you plan to do
that the executive order will be it's
being written now as we speak probably
tomorrow sometimes will it have
exemptions in there will have certain
exemptions because you're gonna need
certain exemptions but we'll be
notifying you tomorrow we'll sign it
most likely tomorrow being drawn now and
tonight and it's something we have to
have in this country we have to have it
people who say it doesn't track with
opening up
the country to shut down immigration
across-the-board for companies that and
and the pipeline that's already in place
what do you say to them well I think it
really does I think it's very strong
obviously and it's countrywide as
opposed to specifically like China or
some of the other ones that I've shut
down we're going to see it you'll see a
very accurate definition tomorrow after
it's completed by the attorneys last
thing for maybe uh North Korea what do
you what can you tell us about the
status Kim Jong well these are reports
that came out and we don't know we don't
know I've had a very good relationship
with them I wouldn't you know I can only
say this I wish him well because if he
is in the kind of condition that the
reports say that the news is saying
there'll be a that's a very serious
condition as you know but I wish him
well then we've had a good relationship
I've said it and I've said it many times
if somebody else were in this position
we would have been right now at war with
North Korea and we're not at war and
we're nowhere close to war with North
Korea so I just have to say to Kim
jong-un I wish him very you know good
luck good luck I mean they came out with
very very serious medical reports
nobody's confirmed that it's was C and
then that came out so when CNN comes out
with the report
I don't place too much credence in it at
all did he convince you of a need for
expanded testing or talk on testing and
we have an agreement we have an
understanding on testing and they have
labs tremendous labs as you know in New
York especially in the Manhattan area
but all over the state in great great
medical schools and federal labs so we
we have a very good understanding we're
going to do very significant testing you
know not everybody wants to do such
significant testing testing is good in
some cases and in some cases it's not
you have governors that don't want to go
all out on the testing because they
think they can do it in a different
manner and and do it better but we had a
very good meeting today the governor and
I had a very
they're not federal aid that can be used
to help governor's who want to expand
testing because we keep here yet all the
way out on 25 billion dollars and that's
a tremendous amount of money that's a
much far more money than in my opinion
that we'll need and again already we're
testing more by far than any country I
think I read yesterday a report that
we've done more than everybody else
every other country combined and I think
our people should be getting a lot of
credit for that we've done a lot more
than everybody else combined and you
never hear that in the news it's you
know unfortunate yep it's probably
that's bad on the executive order
presenting you meant indeed there gonna
be some exemptions we're reporting right
now that only applies to employment in
Greek Greek arts for employment and not
for those four we're gonna be reporting
on that later on it might be tonight or
tomorrow we'll give you an executive you
said people who may be worried about the
people in your immediate family no I
think it's been covered pretty
accurately in this case I think most
people know what it is and some people
will be able to get in we have to do
that obviously even from a UMaine
standpoint but they'll be there'll be
some people coming in but it's a it's a
strong order just a big big circle as
you know please
immigrants who are already in the
country are they a greater risk of
deportation based on this order I don't
think I don't think so they're not
supposed to be here you're saying
they're here illegally is that what you
say well for example if an immigrant is
here for a court order then you have to
go to court so then the judge would make
a determination as to whether or not
they're going to be staying but if they
have a court order they won't have to
leave until they go through that process
so we'll see what happens but with the
court and there are some with court
orders that means they have a trial
coming up please it's so obviously on
the immigration executive order you
raise concern for a long time even in
good economic times about immigrants
taking Americans jobs so under what
conditions would you consider
fifteen this halt on immigration yeah
it's sort of an opportunity to address
what you've seen as a problem for a long
time well I think right now obviously
there's never been we're the greatest
economy in the world and then one day we
had to shut it down they said you have
to shut it down we did the right thing
because I think we would have had a
million or maybe even two million or
maybe more than that death so we did the
right thing but certainly this would
pertain I mean when you look at it right
now the last thing we want to do is take
American workers jobs it's one thing
when we were essentially they used to
call it full employment and it's another
thing right now right now we have people
that have lost their jobs and we hope
they're going to come back and come back
fast and that we can have an even deeper
discussion but right now we have to have
jobs for Americans the Japanese sense of
like if unemployment gets to 4% or 5% I
love to see I mean I hope we're in that
position to have that debate right now
we're not in that position right now we
closed down a the largest economy the
greatest economy in the history of the
world it's the most successful economy
when you look at the stock market we're
breaking records
virtually every week sometimes every day
and stock markets still not doing badly
considering what this country has been
through which tells you how strong it
was in the first place but no I hope
we're going to be able to have that
discussion I hope we're in a position
that's like a good discussion to have
but that'll be a little bit later Brett
for dr. Burks
about the CDC director said in an
interview that perhaps this net second
wave of coronavirus in the fall could be
worse because it is timed with the
seasonal flu
just wondering if you can talk about
that in context of as you're opening up
the country and these guidelines that
you've laid out so we were very clear in
the guidelines that we believe we can
monitor again monitor communities at the
community level by using the influenza
like illness and the cinder ohmic
respiratory and gastrointestinal
components of this of this particular
virus obviously when we have flu we're
going to and we're working on an
algorithm that you test for flu and then
you test for covet and making sure that
we are building the testing capacity to
be able to do that because I think it's
very important that you're going to be
able I on the surface a patient when
they come in with early flu and early
kovat can look very close to get
identical so we need to have testing in
place to be able to separate and ensure
those patients or see the best treatment
we're also hoping by that time that we
have additional treatment options for
people with kovat 19 so that there will
be additional treatment available in the
fall the president has made it clear
that we have the emergency which we have
been working on the opening up
guidelines and just like he talks about
phase four he has us very much working
on the next 6090 and for all on with
fall and that's why he's not stopped any
of the ventilator orders it's very
important that we have a completely
refreshed and a comprehensive stockpile
going into the fall and I think that's
why we continue to bring in those
shipments and work on the ventilators so
that those would be available not only
for the United States but certainly if
other other partner countries have this
duda level of tragedy so you agree this
could come back actually worse in the
fall there will be worse I think this
has been pretty bad when you see what
has happened in New York that was very
bad I believe that we'll have early
warning signals both from our
surveillance that we've been talking on
in these on the vulnerable populations
we're going to continue that
surveillance from now all the way
through the fall to be able to give us
that early warning signal I think what
we've learned is how good Americans are
about immediately reverting to all of
those issues that they need to do in
order to ensure that they're protected
and their families mr. president what do
you say there's concerns like Georgia is
opening up barber shops and bowling
alleys in the light and you saw Lindsey
Graham is saying he's concerned the
Georgia may be going too far too fast
and it could affect people in South
Carolina obviously people travel back
and forth between states how do you
protect the people of South Carolina for
example from a potentially bad decision
by a governor in Georgia so he's a very
capable man he knows what he's doing
he's done a very good job as governor
Georgia and and by the way in South
Carolina Governor McMaster also so you
have two very capable people we're gonna
find out and in fact I'm scheduled to
speak to the governor of Georgia in a
little while but will will find its
concern that what happens in Georgia I'm
concerned about what happens everywhere
I mean we've got those concerns and as
far as coming back if they do come back
and they could come back together with
heavy on the flu and much lighter on
because I really believe we'll be able
to put out the fires you know it's like
fires and we've learned a lot you know
we've become very good at this when you
look at what's happening when you look
at the numbers coming down a lot of
states are in really great shape you're
gonna see a lot of openings but I'll be
speaking to the governor of Georgia in a
little while yeah we could be prepared
for going back to social distancing even
if things relaxed over the summers over
the summer come the fall comes back in
command I'll speak for the doctor and if
you'd like you to say but I would say
that you keep away or until this thing
is gun it's gonna be gone at some point
it's gonna be gun gun and I would say
you keep away and you do the social
distancing until such time as you know
it's gone we'll know when that time is
your executive order is through the last
for 60 days how will you decide whether
to accept
well I look at autonomy see where we are
with the economy basically and I think
I'll have a very easy decision to make I
hope I hope that the economy is going to
be great by that time but we'll see but
right now in light of the fact that
Americans are out of jobs I can't be
have I can't be taken in for another 60
days well I could or I could roll it for
30 days or I could roll it for much more
than 60 days we have to take a look at
the time but we'll be looking at 60 days
and we'll see what it is you go why
don't you go and then you will continue
with that there is reporting that you
may actually sign a second order to even
limit more than exceptions that you were
just talking about can you confirm it if
I want but I won't be doing it tomorrow
I'll be signing the primary order and
then we have a secondary order that if I
want to do that will make that
determination we can do that yeah we can
do that at a little bit different time
if we want that is under consideration
at the secondary orders yeah please
Thank You mr. president I have two
questions one from me and one from a
reporter who couldn't be in the room
because of so my first question is about
your immigration order you campaigned on
reducing legal immigration I remember
your speech in Phoenix and 2016 on
reducing legal immigration and illegal
but no I've always said you have to come
into the country legally
so not legal what I campaigned on was
people just flooding our border and
stopping and by the way speaking of that
we have a hundred and seventy miles
almost 170 miles of a very powerful
border wall up and it's moving rapidly
very quickly and it's having a
tremendous impact and it's making our
job a lot easier plus Mexico has 27,000
soldiers right now on our southern
border that we share with them and
Mexico has been terrific they've really
helped you also campaigned on reducing
legal immigration and I'm wondering if
some critics are saying that you are
using the virus now in this
crisis to follow through on that promise
to reduce legal No well I want people
that are in this country I want our
citizens to get jobs I don't want them
to have competition we have a very
unusual situation where something came
in that nobody has seen for many many
decades probably 1917 would be the
closest analogy if you look at it when
you look at the contagion the kind of
contagion we're talking about so no I'm
not I'm not doing that at all I want I
want the American worker and the
American our American citizens to be
able to get jobs I don't want them to
compete right now there's a big
difference when we have a full economy
and frankly where some of the companies
we have many companies moving in where
they need actually they need workers
that's a big difference between that and
where all of a sudden a lot of people
lose jobs as you know a lot of farmers
rely on seasonal migrant workers the
farmers will not be that's an important
point the farmers will not be effective
yeah that's very important point I mean
it's a great point actually I've I'm
glad you brought it up no the farmers
will not be affected your your they
stopped everybody from coming in and all
the farmers went out of business they
were literally at a business you
remember that bread it was not so long
ago but they it's easy you know it's
easier to stop everything cold than it
is to plant it so that the farmers have
the people that have been working in
those farms for many years and and
that's what we're doing no the farmers
will not be affected by this at all if
anything we're going to make it easier
and we're doing a process that'll make
it better for those workers to come in
to go to the farm where they've been for
a long time for questions for our
reporters out of the room is from the
Washington Times Tom Howell well he
hasn't the CDC the federal government's
main disease fighting agency had a more
public facing role and they'd the
pandemic if it was holding regular media
calls early on that has not held one
since early to mid march well I can't
tell you that CDC has been terrific
we've worked with him very closely they
were very much involved even in the
border decision that I made last night
and the directors the directors do
anything
we have always whether it's Tony or
Deborah or Steve we have always a lot of
people up and certainly had you've seen
the directors been here a lot right he's
been here he's been sitting here has
been speaking a lot
no no CDC is very much involved and
everything we've done the director the
CDC said that protest against stay at
home ours are not helpful you've
encouraged some of these protests what
are your thoughts on the CDC director
saying people look it's not a question
of helpful or not people want to get
back to work and I've watched some of
the protests not in great detail but
I've seen that and they're separated
they're a lot of space in between I mean
they they're watching believe it or not
social they're doing social distancing
if you can believe it and they are and
they're protesting but that they're the
groups I've seen have been very much
spread out so I think that's good look
people they want to get back to work
they got to make a living they have to
take care of their family they don't
want to do this it's a you know
unfortunate maybe one way or the other
both are unfortunate both are
unfortunate but you have a lot of people
out there that are anxious to get back
people are actually more concerned more
people are concerned about the virus
spread they don't want to go out there
to groups and they both they're big
groups both of them just what what good
is it for these businesses that would
reopen if the customers are by the same
time we have to build back our country
and I'm going to make our country bigger
and better and stronger and we have to
get started there's a big difference
though because people have really been
through a lot and they understand what
to do now before nobody had ever heard
of a thing like this when you say I mean
nobody ever heard of a thing like this
just in saying social distancing what
does that mean washing your hands every
15 minutes what does that mean I mean
people had never seen or heard about
anything like this now they really are
they they've not only have they done it
but they've done a good job of it but
you're people you can't break the
country at some point you have to go
back now hopefully the governors are
going to do because I want the governors
and I vote
one of that you could go let federalism
you can call it whatever you want but
the governor's I want them to do it if
they if we see them doing something we
don't like we'll stop it very quickly
but they're doing a good job they're
being careful some of the governor's
frankly they're in a position where they
can do it soon or they can do a little
bit later and that's okay but people we
don't want to they they need money they
need help we're gonna lose and we can't
break our country over this we can't do
it we have to get going with that being
said some are gonna go soon and some are
not yeah in the back if I might just I'm
pardon me hair salons
nail salons tattoo parlors dr. Burks can
you weigh in on this because the people
of Atlanta was here from you as well as
much as they want to hear from their
governor how do you 6-7 them safely have
hair salons and nail salons and tattoo
parlors where people where people have
to inherently be close together I think
what I've been trying to communicate
over the last several days is it's
really important that the governors and
mayor's communicate critical information
to their communities and show very
clearly the data we remember we wanted
this data and evidence based the data
that they utilize to make decisions and
the data that the mayor should use in
each of the communities because it will
have to be on a community by community
opening because there are different
communities in different places even in
Georgia and so I believe people in
Atlanta would understand that if their
cases are not going down that they need
to continue to do everything that we
said social distancing washing your
hands wearing a mask in public so if
there's a way that people can social
distance and do those things then they
can do those things I don't know how but
people are very creative so I'm not kind
of prejudged but we have told people
very clearly in the president guidelines
made it very clear about the
expectations of phase one and remember
phase one also included social
distancing and restaurants social
distancing
in every place that was entertainment
and keeping your own individual social
groups - less than ten I mean we've been
very clear in the guidelines and I think
it's up to the governors and mayor's to
ensure that they're following the best
they can each of those phases to make
sure that both of the public is
completely protected but the governors
and mayor's also need to communicate
very clearly on the data that was used
for decision-making and make that
transparent and available to their
communities an example that you just
gave are they doing testing before they
go in we have to find that out that's
why I'm speaking to the governor a
little while and I'll be asking those
questions please Thank You mr. president
just trying to get a sense of what you
have left my toolbox as it relates to oh
you you hashed out the deal with hope
that bus you order for purchases into
the SPR I mean what else can be the
biggest thing that the toolbox is to get
our country open that's by far the
biggest thing there is if we can open
pretty well and I think we're going to
over a period of time piece by piece
puzzle remember if we can open well I
think that's your biggest part by far
that's where the engine is more
important than any other thing that we
can work on please go to New York
related questions in your meeting with
Governor Cuomo was there talked about
providing states like New York with aid
in the fourth stimulus package wondering
if you have any thoughts on whether that
aid should be tied to infection rates
whether states like New York New Jersey
that have been hardest hit should
receive more money and also wondering if
you have any thoughts on Mayor Bill de
Blasio saying today that he'd like to
host ticker-tape parade of sorts once
this is all over to honor the health
care workers that sounds like a good
idea to me when it's all over it sounds
like a great idea they deserve it
they're warriors they've done an
incredible job we mentioned briefly the
state aid we talked about that Governor
Cuomo myself and I agree with him on
that and I think most Republicans agree
too and Democrats and that's part of
phase four and I think infrastructure is
going to be a big part we have to
rebuild our country
I mean you take a look where we spent
and we go over this all the time but
eight trillion dollars in the Middle
East we want to rebuild our country and
that means our bridges or tunnels even
schools we're doing something with
schools we have to do our roadways that
what's happened we spent so much money
on other countries that don't even that
they don't appreciate it okay they don't
appreciate it we're gonna spend money
now on our country and we're gonna have
it's gonna be our jobs and it's gonna be
our equipment it's gonna be made much of
it is gonna be made here hopefully at
some point all of its gonna be made here
John mr. president at that podium back
on March 9th vice president pence said
that over a million tests had been
distributed and then he said this exact
quote before the end of this week
another four million tests will be
distributed as you know now six weeks
later we still aren't at four million
tests I don't know whether salmon with
the testing ready are you ready again
I'll say it for the fifth time we have
tested more than any country in the
world and some of the countries are very
big okay more than any country in the
world we have one of the most successful
if you call mortality rates because one
person and I always say that for you in
particular one person is too many but
we've done very well
our testing if you add them all up we've
tested more now I don't know what Mike
Pence said but I'm sure he could answer
that there's four million tests and
we're we're ready again we've tested
more than every country in the world
even put together so that's all I can
say as far as Mike he'll answer your
question back to the China deal and to
face one of this China yeah the flight
ban is still in place how confident are
you that the Chinese are not going to
use invoke the natural disaster clause -
just wait before getting into the
gonna say look there's nobody ever been
tougher on China than me and that means
for 20 years you go back 20 years I
probably got elected at least partially
on the fact that I've been very tough I
said China's been ripping us off for
years I'd go into Michigan I'd go into
Pennsylvania make speeches unrelated to
being a politician I'd be invited I'd be
speaking to people which I like to do
because I love the people I love the
people of this country and I'd make
speeches nobody I'd say how did you let
this happen with China I even asked the
leaders of China how how did this ever
happen where our country loses tens of
billions of dollars a year and I don't
mean just tens take a look two hundred
billion three hundred billion four
hundred billion five hundred billion
dollars a year how did they ever let a
thing like this happen now if you look
at this last year the deficit went way
down and I'm talking about even before
now it's much different but a lot of
things are happening great things were
happening except all of a sudden out of
nowhere came the invisible enemy and we
think we know where it came from and
we'll be talking about that probably a
lot but came the invisible enemy there's
been nobody tougher than me on China no
guarantee that they are going to go
ahead with this but if that happens
we'll do a termination and we'll do what
I can do better than anybody yeah please
intelligence analysts told you that they
think that the virus escaped from a
Chinese research lab that it was a well
I can't have US intelligence agents told
me I mean what kind of a question you
said do you feel I can't I can't you
want me to tell you let me tell you what
they told me look they told me plenty
they told me plenty Brett I want to
follow up one you said about the small
business program Harvard is going to pay
the money back how confident are you
that you can claw back money well I said
look I don't like what Harvard that has
I think 40 billion dollar endowment to
some incredible amount of money that
Harvard gets this money Harvard you paid
that money back I want Harvard to pay
the money back
they won't do that then we won't do
something else they have to pay it back
I don't like it I don't like it this is
meant for workers this isn't meant for
one of the riches institutions not only
far beyond schools in the world they got
to pay it back
I want them to pay it back
your Florida clubs have had to Pearl oh
yeah have you thought about asking your
family members not allowed to have the
golf courses off but you can't have the
clubs opened can't have anything it's a
it's a big hotel and and Resort and I
think it was probably 700 750 people so
you can't have anything open and you say
what are we gonna do have full payroll
and have the whole place with you no
there's no income coming in first who
everyone's home and they're supposed to
be second Omo Florida you can't use golf
courses that one I'm not sure I agree
with you know you have parks and golf
courses where you have open space but
that's what it is so I have others also
that I have others in different states
have a lot of different properties but
again my children run them and I love my
children and I wish them well I look
forward to comparing my numbers to my
children's numbers I think I'll do
better you might be part of accurate you
want to say that it's called the closed
property is like you know you have to
close them up and then hopefully when
things get better we'll just open it up
but you can't have you know many
hundreds of employees standing around
doing nothing there's no customer you're
not allowed to have a customer so in
some places it's very strict New Jersey
strict New York is strict and you have
to do what you have to do and it's too
bad I feel so badly when I say that I
think that it's a tough policy but I go
by whatever the policy that's a state
policy in the case of Florida
you've communicated regularly with kim
jang of the north korean leader are you
gonna try to reach out to him to check
on his condition I'm a what I look I
just hope he's doing fine I mean I've
had a very good relationship with Kim
jong-un and that's to the benefit of the
country that's not a bad thing that's a
good thing
and I'd like to see him be well and
we'll see how he does again I don't know
that the reports are true line of
succession as far as I know I don't want
to ask them that I have asked him that
but itself it's not it's not my purpose
to tell you that in all fairness but you
know I hope he does well doctor you
don't mind I just wanted to follow up on
the question we're asking you about with
social distancing in some of these
states so you know with Georgia opening
back up you know things like tattoo
parlors getting a massage social dissing
maybe there are some creative ways but
it seems very difficult to do social
distancing so do you have a message for
people in Georgia who are soon gonna
have a choice about going at the hair
salon or the nail salon or getting that
tattoo if they're not six feet apart and
they're not able to follow these social
distancing guidelines what's your
message to people on Penn State like
Georgia
well we made it very clear in a message
to all of the American people with
opening up America again the criteria
that we wanted States to follow those
were careful criteria there were only
six they were carefully carefully
selected in conversations with
epidemiologists around the world and
with CDC to really pick things that
people could understand and use
platforms that people have utilized in
the past but it was built on the premise
that it needs to be data-driven and it
needs to protect those who are most
vulnerable and then it went through the
phases and the very first thing it says
in all phases all individuals need to
continue to wash hands protect the
vulnerable ensure the safety of others
but in phase one it made it clear that
social distancing was absolutely key and
I think it's on the White House website
and we asked every American to read it
and to use that as their guidelines now
we've also asked governor's to create
county level information so that
communities can see the information and
understand why they may be different
than a different County so that it's
very transparent and understandable I
had a question here a couple of days ago
on a Jacksonville Beach and Jacksonville
is dramatically different than Miami and
I think that was reflected in why
Jacksonville had a different set of
information and regulations so I'm not
gonna second you know judge anyone about
their decision-making what I'm going to
say is we were very clear and what we
really believe protects the safety of
Americans and that is clearly laid up I
laid out in the opening up America again
I have a question because we got Dana
from Tokyo an increase of cases and a
double of the cases in Singapore what
we've been you know looking a lot at
Europe after China and then we're back
into this area of the world here we're
not get about a plateau and then cases
going down any lessons to take out of
what we what's happening in this area in
Asia after I've been put our attention
somewhere else for a song for so long
the lesson is to be careful there's got
to be very careful we don't want that to
happen it could happen I think we stamp
it out if it does happen we're not gonna
be doing any mass closings I hope so I
think we could you know I called some
burning embers and we put them out and I
think we've gotten very good at that but
we'll see but we don't want that to
happen now absolutely because Oh mr.
president what's the reopening happen we
won't need to go back into reclosing I
don't want to do that you don't want to
do that nobody in this room wants to do
that you look forward I think Brett very
soon and John sitting next to a lot of
your fellow reporters right the room
seems so empty this way but it's one of
those things yeah go ahead please
on the topic of public support and it
says USA Today poll just came out and
found 80 percent of Americans are
supportive of the immigration call the
temporary for yes did that have any
public support have any effect on your
decision-making here and are you
surprised by those numbers yeah it's a
high number I did not see that number I
heard there was a poll I'm sure there'll
be a lot of polls no look I think the
American people want to make sure that
they have jobs for the American people
not for people that come in in many
cases illegally into our country so
we're doing that I don't know what the
numbers are but I think just common
sense tells you that's where we should
be and that's where the American people
want to be and we're going to build our
country back and I'm telling you with
all the things that we're doing and
infrastructure which we desperately need
it's going to be an incredible thing
taking but it's going to be a
Renaissance so we're gonna have
something that will be a lot of people
going to go to work building those roads
and bridges and tunnels and highways and
all of the other things we're going to
be building and broadband for the Middle
West I mean the farmers haven't been
treated fairly let's face it the farmers
have been treated terribly when it comes
to the internet so we're going to take
care of that we're going to we're gonna
make them very happy so we'll see you
all tomorrow and we'll have some
interesting things to put out tonight
and I appreciate you being here and it's
an honor to have Britt bear here I've
used his slot a lot younger use that
slot at all